what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
dr umar johnson the video is titled
black sun
only wants to date white girls now
and as you guys know uh my boyfriend's
black
not that it matters like at all but it's
a little interesting like listening to
him because he's so against that
so let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or disagree with me
um and don't forget to subscribe again
i'm trying to get to 15
000 subscribers this week that is my
goal
okay let's start this reaction
black women are losing because of black
men not being
exclusive in their dating choices you
have to tell your son that
and you need to let them know it's not
because of hate
this has nothing to do with hating white
women
okay let me i have two questions
for what i've heard from like just
listening to these youtube videos
is that that's not actually true like 85
percent of black men marry black girls
let me know in the comments if that's
true but it's still a pretty high
percentage
i've also heard that
um i've read the other thing i was gonna
say hold on
that women lose i don't know it has to
do with
rebuild oh sorry i remembered i also
heard that he never married a black girl
like he didn't marry the mother of his
kids
so isn't that a little hypocritical
holding the black empire
it's about rebuilding the african world
it's about rebuilding the black
community
if black women will not tell their sons
that they must be loyal to black women
if your mother if a mother
can't tell a black boy that you should
be loyal to black women
then no matter who else tells them that
it will not matter it got to come from
y'all
or it can't come from anybody i've
actually gotten that from like
an axe was that like we couldn't
be together because of that like
i've heard it before so i don't want to
say like no
nobody's saying that
oh that's just the keep okay now
to the question at hand uh
i'm not sure what it is
with my beautiful black sisters
black mothers but ever since
i went on the breakfast club interview
and had the conversation with my good
friend dj envy
when he asked me you know
whether or not i was recommending that
he tell his son
well he dj envy said i can't tell my son
that he can't date white girls and i
said you better tell him that
okay but since that breakfast club
interview
so many black mother to so many black
mothers to my amazement
to my amazement so many black women have
come
forward to express to me that they have
a problem
telling their black sons that they
should only date black women and i'm
just
amazed at
how so many black women don't feel
comfortable doing that
especially given the fact that black
women are the ones
losing out because black men are not
dating black women so
okay i actually have a probably
unpopular opinion
i think you're more than like like
you're more than welcome to tell your
kids to date who they want so
like this seems really controversial but
i was thinking about it a little bit
more
and like a lot of jewish people would
rather date jewish people because they
have like the same culture if like a
black person wants to date another black
person like especially in like a family
because it's the same culture that's
fine
where my issue comes in is when you're
telling
other people in other families that like
maybe the culture like isn't as
important to them like who
they should date and that's where like
my issue comes in
so let me ask you and i know you can
only speak for yourself but this is such
a bigger issue
why for you why do you have a problem
telling your son
to be loyal to black women
i used to actually i used to tell them
all the time
you know find a woman that looks like me
grandma or something like that and then
what what i think was the big shocker
for him
is my like i said he's very close to my
younger brother
and my younger brother was dating this
beautiful sister
had her own business and you know all
this kind of stuff and she actually
helped him get his own business started
and
he left her and he married this little
mountain
girl
you said he married him but see this
this is where
my issue comes in if she wants to tell
her son
hey culture is really important to us
whatever marry him
but now she's worried about like her was
that her cousin her uncle
like and past a certain age you really
can't control what your kids do so it's
cool to tell them that but like
my dad has always instilled in us like
you can do what you want
mountain wait wait wait you said he
married a mountain girl
[Laughter]
she said he married a mountain girl oh
god
okay and like that's that's where she's
from
and like this was a complete
180 like how you go from this sister
like dark skinned sister
beautiful girl to this white girl
and i was pissed i didn't want anything
to do with this girl i was like you know
he's been on and off with this white
girl thing all his life
and then he gets in this serious
relationship with the system we're like
okay he doesn't grow up he got it out of
his system
and all of us he's like well she's too
ghetto for me and he dumps her
so he said the black girl was too ghetto
the blood
so the black woman was too ghetto so he
went and got a mountain girl
what does ghetto mean i mean i've heard
the term but let me know in the comments
what you think
ghetto means what made him say
say that the black girl was too ghetto
he was at her house one night
and she got into a fight with her sister
and he couldn't break them up he
couldn't make herself
but the mountain
i mean that's a valid reason to break up
with somebody
like lack of conflict resolution that's
like absolutely a good reason to break
up
some with someone how they fight with
their family
because that's that'll tell you how
they're going to fight with you someday
mountain girl is probably more ghetto
than the sister
those mountain folks them hillbillies is
worse than the hood people they worse
so that was an excuse as far as i'm
concerned
like i said he got with this girl and
like i was so against it
but and that you know not to take
anything away from her she's not a she's
not a terrible person
but i would i would if i could choose my
brother's name
i would have decided i would have chosen
for him to work out with the sister he
was with
but you know that was his decision
that's a grown man but like
but let me get back to my question for
you though why okay
but i felt like i couldn't pull my son
away from that but
okay but that okay his relationship with
his uncle because his uncle marries this
white girl
no you don't have to re you don't have
to ruin the relationship with the uncle
okay let's sit here and an aunt has a
white
husband and none of my sisters are
married to white men thank god
but let's say the aunt has a white
husband she can still
hang out with aunt but guess what i'm
going to make sure my sister
understands that the only lesson you
give in my child
as it relates to dating is
she will date black men and if you
cannot reinforce that
don't even bring up dating that's
something y'all will not discuss
i will handle that myself that's what i
would be telling
my sister okay you can mentor her in
any other you know being a lady business
education
but when it comes to dating because you
made a political mistake against the
race
because you made a see see right there
right there a political mistake against
the race
that that right there too far too far
for me
i just that's kind of weird
political mistake against the race you
can't give my daughter no dating advice
because you are with a mountain man so
since you dating ice people
okay and i only want my daughter date
and son people you don't give out no
advice and i would let my daughter know
over and over what it is we stand for
but my question to you you seem a little
ambivalent
well you said you used to tell your son
to be to only date black girls but then
you stop
why did you stop giving him that
principle to live
i guess by that's one of the biggest
folks my family
the elders in the family and now that
she's married to
my brother she is
like she's so it's like
you got to respect her so i don't want
him to like come out his mouth wrong at
her
like you know mom she'll be married
anyway like i don't want him to do it
not that i think he would but i don't i
don't want disrespect
but it's not disrespect it's not
disrespect
but it's not disrespectful
those are the principles listen jewish
people don't invite black people to the
synagogue
ever ever
it's not disrespectful they are just
for themselves so we got this
we got one of the biggest problems we
have to get over with this is our new
year's resolution
black people have to get more
comfortable being
unapologetically african we have to stop
feeling that is wrong to be totally
and exclusively dedicated to ourselves
and this that's that's where he loses me
again if you want to say
we i want someone with similar values
culture whatever
that makes sense to me but where you get
it
like well you get off telling people
with completely different cultures so
let's say like
someone from canada and jamaica they're
going to be completely different
in terms of like culture values whatever
like that are both black
but they only need to date someone
that's black but they might not have
anything in common with like
that doesn't make sense and that's why i
say like worry about your own family
like i if people wanted to dm me ask me
for dating advice whatever
they could but like in all honesty i do
not care what other people do i care
what i do
i might be entertained by it like i do
love watching the kardashians on social
media
but like i really don't care but
it's very entertaining anyways my two
cents and the reason why we got to
change this
is our whole resurrection depends upon
this mental shift i we will get nowhere
economically financially spiritually
socially
we will get nowhere until we change this
sick mindset
that slavery gave us okay
what evidence does he have of that being
true
i don't know it could be but it sounds a
little bit like nonsense to me
like seriously look
like a lot of different groups of people
were enslaved over the years
like throughout history what evidence is
there
that like that what he is saying is true
we got this from
slavery of having to approve of
everybody else even when it's
within our even when it's not in our own
best interest black women are
losing because of this black women are
losing because of black men not being
exclusive
in their dating choices you have to tell
your son that
and you need to let them know it's not
because of hate this has nothing to do
with hating white women
it has to do with rebuilding the black
empire
it's about rebuilding the african world
okay what does it mean to rebuild the
black empire because
in order for me to agree or disagree
with his statement he would have to be a
little bit more specific
on what exactly he means by rebuilding
the black empire
um does that just mean like increase
increasing the economic
like outcomes of like the black
community or is he
speaking and if that is what he's
talking about
how does marrying within your race
affect you economically
it's about rebuilding the black
community
if black women will not tell their sons
that they must be loyal to black women
if your mother if a mother can't tell a
black boy
that you should be loyal to black women
then no matter who else tells them that
it will not matter it got to come from
y'all
oh it can't come from anybody
i got a question hold on hold on let me
let hold on let me finish with the queen
first
what are your thoughts on that sister
i mean i agree with you um my like i
said my biggest concern
my biggest concern is
i guess because i'm so family oriented
and it's
it's a lot race mixing is a lot in my
family i have a
lot of oh i see what you're saying so
this thing okay
okay okay okay and whatnot that have
dated or married white women and asian
women
and like
you don't have to keep him away from
nobody listen
you don't have to keep him away from
nobody he can still
go around his white aunts with their
white husbands and he could go around
his black
uncles with their white wives he can
still be around
everybody he just knows that
that ain't the way i'm going to be
living my life that's all
he ain't got to talk about it he ain't
got to debate it he ain't got the
defendant it doesn't even have to be
discussed
he simply knows that you are raising him
with a code of honor that they were not
raised with that's all
it doesn't have to be these little a
conversation crushers come home i need
to dab that immediately
yes yes
you can tell him you can be friends with
him and of course we know you can't have
white friends but he's not there yet
but they can wait what
what you could you can socialize with
them you can associate with them
okay nothing's wrong with that but you
ain't dating we don't do that in here
you will only date black women i have a
quick question
go ahead okay
i'm from chicago my son he's 14 years
old
he just started high school so you've
been around black girls all this time
and my worst fear has come to fruition
this little white girl that goes to his
school is like
baby stop still right white girl goes to
school
about the only white girl i'm like what
do i do
his dad is muslim so i'm telling him
like we don't live together he was he'd
been incarcerated my whole son
life just until this year he just got
out of prison so he's trying to adapt
i'm coming to him i'm like look you need
to tell your son
that he cannot date because i'm telling
him
he can't i'm like you can't date her
she's like mom why what's wrong
why is this why does her skin color
matter i'm like
i'm not trying to sound racist because
now he's learning
sounding a little racist i don't know
about this race
racist um they teaching them about
racism and all this other stuff
you know all the stuff in the news and
so now he's calling me a racist
i'm like i'm not a racist but
i just think that's that we're racist
well wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
back up
you said he asked you why can he date
the white girl
what did you tell him no he said mom why
does her color matter
and what did you tell him you gotta
answer that he asked you a good question
i'm not
saying that um
i'm just saying for him i said jay i
feel like for you
um black only the black girl is going to
understand you because you're a black
boy
and i said i just don't agree
with you dating somebody else out of
your leagues and he's like mom why does
your color matter
i'm like so it's like i'm not trying to
sound racist
your mom you sound racist though i'm
like oh my god
wait wait wait i'm still not clear
he'll grow out of it ain't nothing wrong
with a little um
ain't nothing wrong with a little
marshmallow or something he said like
he'll grow out of it
so you know he he um he grew up around
the whole family like we're
mostly for all blacks so it's just like
why did my son
out of all people i mean i don't even
know how this even happened
so i don't even know what to do but your
aunt i don't think your answer was
sufficient
when he asked you why does color matter
you said
i'm not trying to be racist that means
you went on the defensive
that shouldn't have been the answer i'm
not trying to be racist you don't have
to try to be racist you can't be racist
racism is a group system racism is a
group system that is created by
a group implemented by the entire group
who has systematic and economic
advantage
over another people's opportunities the
only way you can be racist
against white folk is if you okay
look i hear what he's saying but guys
come on
you're telling me if somebody like let's
just let's just say
hypothetically there's a black person
who murdered a white person just because
they were white
you're telling me that wouldn't that
wouldn't be racist come on
come on exercise some degree of control
over economics and the political reality
of waifu
yeah that's somebody who need to mute
their phone somebody got the wind
blowing
but if you don't control opportunities
if you don't control
wealth if you don't control institutions
how can you be re
to be racist you have to be able to
exercise
power i don't know you pick up a gun you
got a lot of power
in the hypothetical scenario i was
talking about to be racist you have to
be able to exercise
power systematically against another
community
you can't be racist as one person
there's no such thing as a one person
racist
because every day i'm keeping i'm
keeping logs about
when he's seeing this girl what they
talking about because i don't want her
to be with her i mean
then tell him that tell him that
i would have no problem telling my
daughter you're not dating any white
boys
we don't do that and then i'm going to
explain to her why
okay and that's what you have to do with
him
um yeah this guy is not my cup of tea
kind of he's okay i
i can understand like a preference but
to say you
like you can't
like past a certain age good luck
anyways let me know if you think i'm
completely lost in the comments
or if you agree with me either way let
me know in the comments
i will talk to you guys next time